i
rusia confirmó el inicio de una nueva
fase centrada en la liberación completa
de las regiones prorrusas de donges y
lugansk moscú dio un ultimátum de
rendición a los militares su craneanos
se mariupol donde se cree que al menos
1000 civiles están escondidos en
refugios bajo una planta siderúrgica
una investigación periodística de la
organización canadiense citizen lab
destapó un espionaje masivo con el
programa israelí pegasus con más de 60
líderes y políticos independentistas
catalanes y vascos desde 2015 los
líderes catalanes han pedido
explicaciones al actual gobierno español
ampliamos desde barcelona
reino unido el primer ministro británico
boris johnson compareció ante el
parlamento por primera vez desde que
fuera multado por las fiestas durante la
pandemia el próximo jueves se votará si
se investiga si el primer ministro
mintió o no al parlamento conectamos
desde londres
bienvenidos a un nuevo informativo de
france 24 6 rodrigo sedano y es un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos este informativo
en ucrania porque el ministro de
relaciones exteriores de rusia serguéi
lávrov confirmó este martes el inicio de
una nueva fase de la llamada operación
militar especial de moscú entretanto las
fuerzas del kremlin han tomado el
control de la ciudad de cree mina en el
este de ucrania según el gobernador
regional moscú dice que lanzó docenas de
ataques aéreos en todo el este del
territorio ucraniano durante la noche
la intensa noche de bombardeos en sum y
en el noreste de ucrania los
trabajadores de emergencia limpian lo
que queda de las casas el ministerio de
defensa ruso asegura que sus tropas
atacaron 60 sitios militares ucranianos
en la madrugada después de que moscú
iniciará el lunes por la noche una nueva
ofensiva en la región de bombas
la operación en el este de ucrania fue
lanzada tal y como fue anunciado desde
el principio para liberar completamente
a las repúblicas de donges y lugansk en
la región oriental es mayoritariamente
de habla rusa y los separatistas
respaldados por moscú llevan ocho años
luchando contra las fuerzas ucranianas
el ejército ruso tomó este martes la
ciudad oriental de cree mina el
gobernador regional dijo que las tropas
ucranianas se habían retirado de la
ciudad las fuerzas rusas están atacando
ahora las posiciones ucranianas a lo
largo de los 480 kilómetros de la línea
del frente regis que ocupó a los
ocupantes rusos han intensificado las
operaciones ofensivas a lo largo de toda
la línea de contacto los principales
esfuerzos del enemigo se centran en
romper la defensa de las tropas
ucranianas en lugar riesgos esta
hospedería de la región desde un jet los
residentes fueron evacuados antes del
nuevo asalto las autoridades ucranianas
instalaron a los habitantes de donbass a
huir hacia el oeste aunque suspendieron
las evacuaciones por tercer día
consecutivo de las ciudades en primera
línea debido a los continuos combates y
en mariupol se cree que al menos 1000
civiles están escondidos en refugios
subterráneos bajo una enorme planta
siderúrgica las autoridades de la
localidad dijeron que eran en su mayoría
mujeres niños y ancianos pero también
están escondidos dentro algunos miembros
del ultranacionalista batallón azor
rusia había dado un ultimátum a los
soldados atrincherados en mariupol para
que se rindieran y depusieran las armas
antes del mediodía hora local
posteriormente anunciaron un corredor
humanitario para aquellos militares que
aceptaron deponer sus armas ucrania no
ha reconocido ninguna rendición por el
momento y moscú espera tomarse este
martes la asediada planta ya zeus tal
negándose a rendirse la planta de acero
azov tal es uno de los últimos focos de
resistencia del ultranacionalista
batallón azor conocidos en mariupol y
ahora es el foco de los bombardeos rusos
en la ciudad portuaria arrasada mientras
moscú intensifica su ofensiva para tomar
el este de ucrania
junto a lo que queda de la resistencia
de la ciudad también se informa que hay
más de mil civiles refugiándose bajo
tierra
hay cientos de civiles en la fábrica a
shocks tal entre ellos hay muchas
mujeres niños y ancianos los ocupantes
rusos son conscientes de que hay civiles
aquí pero siguen lanzando bombas de
fragmentación cohetes y todos los
proyectiles de artillería posibles
incluso desde buques de guerra como su
estrés corvil prokopenko hizo un
llamamiento a los líderes mundiales para
que impulsen un corredor humanitario que
permita a los civiles huir ya las
familias enterrar a sus muertos con
dignidad
funcionarios de kiev dijeron que aviones
de guerra rusos se preparaban para
lanzar bombas de 5 toneladas sobre la
planta de azov tal tras casi dos meses
invadiendo ucrania las tropas de
vladimir putin se han visto obligadas a
reagruparse ya han anunciado el inicio
de una nueva fase de la guerra enfocada
en lo que llaman la liberación del
donbass la ciudad clave de mariupol les
permitiría completar un puente terrestre
entre la península de crimea ocupada y
las fuerzas en las regiones separatistas
de don jet-ski lugansk y con motivo de
la cercana pascua ortodoxa el secretario
general de las naciones unidas antonio
terrés pide una pausa humanitaria en
ucrania de cuatro días con el fin de que
los civiles puedan tener un paso seguro
para alejarse de las zonas en conflicto
guterres aseguró que la onu está
presentando planes detallados a ambas
partes y que está preparada para enviar
convoyes humanitarios
dyer las necesidades humanitarias son
extremas la gente no tiene alimentos
suministros de agua para tratar a los
enfermos o heridos o simplemente para
vivir a diario más de 12 millones de
personas necesitan la asistencia
estadounidense en ucrania hoy y de ellos
más de un tercio están en mariupol
gerson donestsk y logan's anticipamos
que esta cifra aumentará a 15 7 millones
eso es alrededor del 40 por ciento de
todos los ucranianos que aún quedan en
el país creen jones la ftc de camps vi
varios líderes mundiales entre ellos el
presidente de eeuu joe biden y el
presidente francés emmanuel macrón
atendieron una reunión virtual para
hablar de los últimos acontecimientos de
la invasión rusa sobre ucrania según la
casa blanca el propósito de la llamada
era textualmente discutir nuestro
continuo apoyo a ucrania y los esfuerzos
para que rusia rinda cuentas como parte
de nuestra estrecha coordinación
el fondo monetario internacional- rebajó
su proyección de crecimiento para 2022 y
2023 como consecuencia de la guerra en
ucrania durante la asamblea conjunta
anual de primavera de este organismo y
el banco mundial el que es uno de los
mayores prestamistas mundiales dijo que
este año el crecimiento global podría
ser del 3 6% y no del 4,4 por ciento que
pronosticaban enero antes de que
comenzara este conflicto para 2023 la
perspectiva es del 36 por ciento un poco
menos que el 38 por ciento previsto hace
tres meses el organismo destaca que la
guerra se produjo justo cuando la
economía mundial comenzaba a sacudirse
de los efectos de la pandemia lo que ya
se notaba con el crecimiento del
producto interior bruto mundial el 61
por ciento el año pasado
en comparación con nuestro pronóstico de
enero hemos revisado a la baja nuestra
proyección de crecimiento global al 3.6
por ciento tanto en 2022 como en 2023
esto refleja el impacto directo de la
guerra en ucrania y las sanciones contra
rusia en ambos países se prevee que se
experimenten fuertes contracciones curso
actions vamos a españa porque una
investigación periodística de la
organización canadiense citizen lab
destapó un espionaje masivo con el
programa israelí pegasus a más de 60
líderes y políticos independentistas
catalanes y vascos desde el 2015 el
programa pegasus solo puede ser comprado
por gobiernos y fuerzas de seguridad y
los líderes catalanes han pedido
explicaciones al actual gobierno español
para ampliar la información conectamos
con nuestra corresponsal en barcelona el
issga single ellis el presidente catalán
acaba de compadecer qué valoración ha
hecho de este caso
pues si el presidente catalán de pega
aragonés que es uno de éstos el 65
catalanes independentistas espiados por
este programa pegasus acaba de denunciar
oficialmente en lo que él llama como lo
que calificó de espionaje masivo a
personas por el simple hecho de pensar
diferente aragonés quien había estado
intentando en normalizar las relaciones
con madrid desde que él llegó al poder
en la región hace ya un año pues dijo
que ya las relaciones con madrid no se
hagan normales tras este caso hasta que
el estado español y más en concreto
hasta que pedro sanz es el presidente
del gobierno español en la 11 una
investigación interna para aclarar quién
les pidió el poder de quién y también
quién sabía de este caso aragonés
también anunció el que pues él
presentará una querella judicial al
título un individual pero también habrá
otras denuncias colectivas como se
anunciaban hoy en bruselas por parte de
otros
entre ellos carles puigdemont líderes de
asociaciones
catalanes denuncias colectivas en otros
países no sólo en españa todo se
denuncia y denuncian hoy en esta rueda
de prensa un ataque a la democracia y
responsabilizan directamente al gobierno
español
incluso el socio de gobierno de pedro
sánchez el partido de izquierdas unidas
podemos ha pedido una investigación
interna pero que ha respondido el
gobierno español y porque se cree que
puede ser responsable de este espionaje
pues justamente hoy este mediodía con
parecía la ministra portavoz del
gobierno español que ella decía que el
gobierno español no tenía nada que
ocultar decía que en españa en mis
espías citó textualmente ni se escuchan
las comunicaciones es si no es por él a
un pago de la ley y por orden judicial
pero esto indigna tanto como la que
habéis deseos también a su socio de
gobierno que pues más viejita al joven
es la ministra de defensa también va a
comparecer el frente al congreso lo haga
en los próximos días y porque ella pues
porque es ministra de defensa y de ella
de su ministerio depende el cine y el
centro de inteligencia español que está
directamente
apuntado en toda la investigación de
citizen lab también provoca tanta
indignación el porque hay otros
políticos no sólo políticos abogados y
parejas de estos políticos y la
investigación también recuerda como lo
acabáis de mencionar que sólo los
gobiernos
pueden pues este pegasus este programa
el catalán no hace nada más que empezar
y tendrá consecuencias políticas
denuncian los independentistas el es
muchas gracias por ampliar nos la
información desde barcelona- estaremos
atentos al desarrollo de esta noticia
nos vamos hasta el reino unido donde el
primer ministro británico gordon son
compareció ante el parlamento por
primera vez desde que fuera multado con
las fiestas en downing street durante la
pandemia el funcionario pidió nuevamente
perdón y además recibió críticas por su
política migratoria y el plan del
gobierno de enviar a ruanda a los
solicitantes de asilo que entren de
forma irregular al país este mismo
martes el presidente del parlamento
británico lindsay hoyle dio luz verde a
una propuesta de la oposición para
debatir y votar el próximo jueves si se
investiga al primer ministro por
presuntamente haber mentido al
parlamento sobre los encuentros que
violaron las restricciones anti kobe 19
para conocer más detalles anteriormente
conectamos con nuestra corresponsal en
londres louis ha pulido
el primer ministro ha pedido disculpas
ha dicho que lo siente que este
comportamiento no se repetirá pero ha
dejado claro que no dará un paso al
costado entre tanto los partidos de
oposición han dicho que es claro que
boris johnson no solamente le metió al
parlamento sino también al público y por
ello debe dar un paso al costado está el
malestar en el parlamento que hemos
visto en la comparecencia de esta tarde
que el jefe del partido laborista de
oposición ha llamado a johnson
deshonesto sinvergüenza y que no respeta
a las instituciones el speaker el
presidente de la cámara de los comunes
le ha pedido hacer quien starmer que
modere su lenguaje en referencia a
johnson johnson durante este debate ha
permanecido cabizbajo y en pocas
oportunidades ha levantado la cabeza
para mirar a sus interlocutores su
futuro por ahora permanece en manos de
su partido el conservador que sigue
manteniendo su confianza en su líder
pero lo cierto es que este panorama
podría cambiar en las elecciones de
regionales del 6 de mayo si los
resultados no son satisfactorios para el
partido conservador
entonces podría convocarse a una moción
de censura y a cinco días de la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones presidenciales
en francia miramos la situación de los
habitantes de pequeños pueblos rurales
como mazón un lugar que encarna las
dificultades de una francia que se
siente olvidada en el momento de elegir
a un nuevo jefe de estado
más son más de 1000 habitantes y un
nivel de participación del 79 en la
primera vuelta
hay que votar es un deber hay que votar
pero entonces a quién debemos votar
una comuna muy movilizada pero que se
manifiesta decepcionada con la política
estamos olvidados siempre piensan en las
grandes ciudades pero en el campo hemos
perdido demasiado en 30 años es sobre
todo eso los hipermercados nos han hecho
mucho daño este habitante recuerda las
decenas de tiendas de macs son hoy
desaparecidas y es que los obstáculos de
la vida rural se acumulan
que vengan y vean por sí mismos las
dificultades que tenemos especialmente
para los que viven así les gustó el
transporte encontrar un médico es
difícil para encontrar una especialista
ahora tienes que viajar 40 kilómetros o
de lo contrario no recibe tratamiento su
sueño
los votantes de marzo seguirán acudiendo
a las urnas del domingo pero sin ninguna
esperanza real de cambio hasta aquí este
informativo sigan conectados a france 24
[Música]